yo soy sordo gusto mudéjar'
y si ambos sentidos ya y es raro el
colegio se equivocan si piensan que me
llamas
de hecho mis amigos variación 17 siendo
hoy a gusto como está haciendo bien y es
interesante saber por qué quiero
comenzar justamente la presentación
un italiano que vino a piura y se casó
con una mujer de pura cepa de sechura ok
entonces es más o menos como espagueti
con chiles enfrenado de mi madre y jara
es el apellido de mi abuelo que era
bueno es un migrante de okinawa que
igual imán y dio su nombre es estar a
punto de se casó con una mujer increíble
con una mujer de la selva peruana y es
algo así como un poco la entonces mis
amigos me dicen chino ok
de digamos de asiático se ve pero de
toda la vida materia tenían que se opone
a que soy pero al final cielo me
presento tío yo soy p igual ok y primera
pregunta que realmente significa ser
peruano y cuál es nuestra entidad como
peruanos entonces básicamente no si los
muchos años atrás y contarles que
estamos en un lugar muy especial ok pero
estar directamente situado al centro de
eso américa en el planeta sur además
tenemos una placa tectónica de forma los
andrés ok y tenemos al final uno del
niño que tiene miles de años que ha
generado un montón de cosas
en él nos han generado recursos a través
de cordillera de nuestro mar del agua y
nos hacen dar una biodiversidad
increíble nos dice que no tiene el 95%
de los cultivos en el global lo cual ha
hecho de perú sea una tierra de viajes
entonces vamos a ir de las estructuras
prehispánicas pre incas de estímulos muy
chic a los xavi que fueron unificados
por los incas a través de la sola lengua
ya la religión más o menos y luego la
vista a los españoles y no la tecnología
la religión entienden entonces además de
la admiración japonés italiana alemana y
tu sobra venezolano y que es lo que hace
realmente eso pero no pues esto somos un
tejido cultural único del mundo cada uno
de ustedes tiene una historia preguntar
a sus padres por esos abuelos que tiene
que merece la pena investigar
ahora porque le falta un poco de estrés
es un poco durante con que hemos hecho
con todo esto realmente punto de estar
en esa cultura y creativa que tenemos el
país recuerden que nuestras culturas
hispánicas no tienen escritura para
tener una riqueza de usuarios y nada que
sabíamos en narrativa que todavía es
máquinas al día de hoy básicamente lo
que hicimos con esta riqueza cultural es
empezar a extraer caucho empezar a
vender guano
y ahora lo que vendemos en piedras lo
que lo cual no está no está mal en una
primera etapa pero que viene más allá es
un poco los ha dejado tener una política
de tranquila de la economía pero por tu
lado
existe una gran oportunidad que se llama
la economía creativa o la economía
naranja te recomiendo más positivo que
la intervención de la economía naranja y
más o menos que es una empresa creativa
economía creativa es todas las
actividades basadas en la creación
humana que tengan alguna forma relación
con una propiedad intelectual
ok representa más o menos el 4.5 de la
economía global si fuera un país sería
el cuarto país del mundo a nivel del pp
y apropiado eeuu en europa lo sagrado en
casi el 7 por ciento ahora todo está
todo esto que nos han contado pues la
empresa creativa cultural incluye no
solamente las artes plásticas y clásicas
de la pintura la cultura del teatro
también las aplicaciones como el cine
mi abuela tienen en flix hoy día ok
todos tenemos spotify ya estamos
viviendo porque no podemos como
liberarlo como industrial hasta de
relatividad
y no sólo eso
esto es un ejemplo de cómo puede
impactar la economía creativa
no sé si conocen quisiera sacar el
brillo de las tres gargantas en china un
proyecto in dome con más de 20 años de
desarrollo muchísimos muertos muchos
impresos para generar que por ciento de
la electricidad china nos costó hacerlo
más o menos 25 mil millones de dólares
pero si nosotros retiramos las 10 obras
del teatro principal en eeuu en taquilla
se genera lo mismo 10 años casi 26.9
millones de dólares ok es una vez una
operación de nada pero parece una idea
del pacto de lo que puede ser los
industria géneros ayuno baile como
estamos posicionado como región todavía
nos falta mucho
estados unidos sigue siendo el portador
máximo de industria creativa hollywood
videojuegos música ok y latinoamérica
está más o menos en 175 mil millones de
dólares
este es el autor de la comunidad
criminal que iba alto que actualmente es
presidente de colombia y templo su
política de estado para diversificación
de la economía es un bastión
importantísimo entre la economía
creativa y el cambio de cambiar la
manufactura por las mentes facturas o
que el interesante que luego que un país
para explicarle al nuestro con muchas
muchas veces es cultural pero que se lo
trata con alestra de una visión arcade
de industria mal humano se tira y hasta
de nosotros entiendan que ya es parte
del portal colombiano
eso es un poco las cifras citados sino
también de las cincos todos en el
informe pero iba muy bien hay mucho que
hacer pero los principales exportadores
de la región viendo sangre de dios ese
vaso de chile chile ahora tiene tres
ejes la minería la batería de las zonas
recreativas ok la música es una
industria súper presente para chile en
la región y más o menos se emplea casi
medio millón de trabajadores de la
triple de la creatividad
qué está pasando
básicamente perú tiene este plan se
provee sea una oportunidad de crecer en
casi 10 mil millones de dólares y pasar
de las números 1.8 2.5 al 5% en los
siguientes 10 a 15 años ok en la teoría
de seguridad perfecta mucho trabajo por
hacer pero más o menos empleadas 100
trabajadores de la creatividad de hecho
estas cifras hay poca ambición en el
tema hay mucho tema tal intencionalidad
no pero es una oportunidad porque somos
reconozcamos que somos un país de
creadores artesanos ok
no soy artista
pero de hecho mi arte es crear
plataformas y metí facturas y desde hace
cinco años vengo creando es también de
factura que se llama arte manifiesto
puntocom que es arte manifiesto puntocom
es básicamente un portafolio en línea
para artistas y creadores visuales ok
porque el artista no recibe mentir que
estudió un lado que fue una charla o que
es título o dueño de su propio vestido
no a un artista local y nivel que es un
portafolio y básicamente eso es no me
flores muestra ok entonces en esta
plataforma cualquier artista de forma
gratuita puede crear puerta fue en línea
y promocionar el mundo
básicamente en comenzamos con la pintura
rápidamente aparecieron lustradores
artistas urbanos y diseñadores
industriales arquitectos hay todo un
universo de creadores visuales en el
perú que no han son obviados y lo
interesante es que incluso también les
han entrat actuadores
interesantes a el puerto ganar un
tatuador de stefano status por ejemplo
que es la tiene tres locales en el miami
otro san francisco tres en lima más o
menos gana como 14 mil soles mensuales
líquidos para el entonces el arte
termina siendo economía
bueno al decir esto de manera
promocional sino que creamos modelos
simples de negocio para los artistas con
su contenido las imágenes el acta puede
crear productos y servicios para
importarlos ok desde grabados digitales
que son cómodos no como sprint son las
impresiones polos carcasas accesorios
leyes etcétera todo se puede fabricar si
es que se hace un buen registro del
audio original no solo eso hemos logrado
consolidar la plataforma más grande de
latinoamérica de creadores visuales con
más de dos mil miembros el 20% son fuera
de perú se ha creado un catálogo de
30.000 logrado en esta plataforma más o
menos se ve como 60 mil obras al mes en
la plataforma eso es mucho más de lo que
puede hacer en un año un museo de arte
de lima vamos a darte un temporal ok acá
creo hacer un vídeo no se pueden
alcanzar
y eso es interesante radio tiene
cantidad infinita de las oportunidades
[Aplausos]
y nunca va a venir todo el espacio para
generar tres vidas para generar
dinamismo para el final ocupar hitos
dentro de lo más comercial porque
tendremos que poner una debilidad si
podemos tomar los espacios que
usualmente no se toma al poner arte y
creatividad e inspirar a miles de
personas a que ese poquito de
credibilidad instancias sus vidas y
desarrollo todos metidos artistas son
realizaron a 200 metros cuadrados en
arte humano el vinilo servimos objetos
así como suya dijo energía de los besos
esta zona de comodidad puede ser
aplicada en cooperación con los
escolares
de hecho más interesante en casa tiene
un millón de personas y visitantes
mensuales estados espacio para responder
los trabajo de estos artistas de cara a
los consumidores digitales
después de la presentación por favor
ahora debo tener previamente las
historias de unos artistas ni protección
artista todo lugar 21 años que él ha
participado de múltiples concursos como
principios de la canal y la de caylon
cayó que cae parado consciente de star
wars ya no ok
realmente el amor compuesto creativo a
nivel global y lo invitaron a las vegas
de san francisco estar en la premier y
no se fue pero no tenía la misma ok
entonces causa el compuesto a pasar dos
días yo lo veo eso es un montón y
entonces no sólo soluciones tristes
aparte por ejemplo de libro que estaba
acondicionada una artista peruana
japonesa ilustradora autodidacta ok el
tema de seguridad en el súper creativo
es súper importante y bueno ella dice
que son los dibujitos pero mire lo que
sus dibujitos pueden hacer de hecho la
gente la presión militar está en
instalar ciudad empecé mi tarea pintar
el que tarda la gente siente eso
disfrazar ya ser cómplice de su
personaje querían salió en su cabeza no
sólo eso la gente se empresa todas sus
obras entonces para que tengan el
infarto puede tener una creación visual
a nivel
como la que tenemos
desatado por ejemplo es un artista
impresionante de hecho casi nadie lo
conoce aquí pero desertó casi está más
tiempo fuera del y mateo lima y le pagan
por lo menos te digo por estimular el
armado de unos 20 mil a 30 mil dólares y
se va a decir por todo y por todo en a
través de invitaciones a festivales de
alto mal a nivel global de hecho ya está
empezando está conectado a la lo que
tiene sentido llegar un poco de color a
la ciudad y le agrede qué actividad hay
talentos hay talentosos artistas sacar
que hay que empezar a mover importante
encontrarse la animación cuando dice el
cuadrito chileno si con directo el
chileno pero con 93 de peruano arona es
un estudio animación que comprar los
derechos y conductos para hacer la
película que es de danza punto confunda
tino américa espero pero es una pasión
súper importante de animación somos
modelos animal
nos exponen además esta noticia de ahí
ahí pues una producción de calidad mixta
realmente porque de un estudio peruano
que ha levantado casi 8 millones de
dólares para hacer la producción en
hollywood de esta película que trata de
los espíritus ancestrales de la selva
que una niña recurre ante la amenaza del
hombre digamos y la civilización ok
entonces siempre di tarea más o menos 23
años pero es una película demasiado
sexual y toda hecha perú entonces la
gente todas las historias indígenas que
tenemos como recursos creativos para
empezar a distribuir salida del cambio
global
bueno solo para trastear unas cosas
primero lo que tenemos que hacer cuatro
retos es reconocieron como país de
creadores
lo segundo es valorar la creatividad no
sé cuando dicen oye porque te voy a
pagar porque has hecho un dibujito la
verdad la creatividad cuesta tiene un
palo y tenemos que respetarlo tanto los
creadores artistas como la gente que lo
consumen los segundos necesitamos
urgentemente políticas públicas que
incentiven las creativas y culturales
recién hace cosas rural y de cine que
generan más o menos en resumen que un
porcentaje de todos los tickets de las
entradas vaya al fondo para financiar
matrículas pruebas pero la música no hay
un solo gremio de artistas hay mucho
todavía por hacer tenemos que facilitar
que el lápiz de acero que tenemos un día
para la creatividad diversidad esa
creativas puede hacer tierra fértil para
que florezcan las canciones y los
creadores peruanos y tercero no sólo
empezamos a ser consumidores tenemos que
también empezar a hacer creadores
sólo para todos es como si fuera que
está en una vaca
pero yo los invito a crear a creer que
esa cadena no está hecho de metal esa
vaca de oro somos todos nosotros esa
riqueza que tenemos en nuestra riqueza
cultural nuestras tradiciones y todos
nosotros juntos así que ahora
[Aplausos]